So we're living in the early days
of a massive paradigm shift.
We are accelerating into a digitized
and decentralized future.
That is why Bitcoin is here.
The cryptocurrency market
has roughly a $3 trillion market cap.
That's the huge milestone.
This is the largest fastest
wealth creation event
in the history of the world
and financial institutions
have only now just figured this out.
The first futures ETF tied to Bitcoin.
This thing is becoming
increasingly entangled
with the mainstream financial markets.
The world's going there.
You know, Bank of America
is now fully engaging in
analysis of crypto broadly.
Never at any point
have we had the freedom
of financial mobility
that we do have now with
blockchain and DeFi.
It is a power to the
people kind of technology.
We're moving to a new kind of world now
where users own their own data,
and they get to run their
own financial services.
However, we are still tied
to the centralized banking system
in a way that is unnecessary.
The crypto sector today
is largely unregulated.
This is a little bit of
like the American wild west.
Essentially, what DeFi is,
it's like a big casino.
That's scary to the JPMorgans
because they're seeing all this
growth and they're left out.
You all can do whatever
you want and I don't care.
You're either in or out.
There's no in-between.
It's pretty much full
service shadow banking
with nobody in charge.
There's an old adage in technology
where they say software is
going to eat everything,
and one can say very clearly
that blockchain is
going to eat everything.
We're seeing a revolution
unfold right now.
These are historic times.
Buckle your seatbelt.
This is where the ride
gets really interesting.
My jacket's in 414 or something.
Oh, yeah.
We got the presidential suite downstairs
for the after party.
I just, okay.
And I left my jacket there
and I just, I will check it on my way out.
Coffee, black.
Bitcoin was the beginning, right?
Bitcoin is where it all started.
What are cryptocurrencies?
They're a type of digital money,
but instead of being controlled
by a central government
they're decentralized using
blockchain technology.
The impetus was the financial
crash of 2008, right?
That's in the white paper of bitcoin.
2008 and Bitcoin gave us
the first spark that
we needed in order to,
you know, start the fire.
We had the same basically
financial systems
in place for hundreds of years.
And now we have this new type
of ledger that's actually
self-auditing by the virtue
of being decentralized.
So that is really the
core of this technology.
So what was once very
obscure magic internet money
is now a global financial infrastructure
that anybody can build on
and anybody can access.
And what this whole movement has grown
into has been like an
evolution of the technology.
The vision has really
always been the same,
decentralizing, democratizing,
returning power to users
of finance or really any
web-based application.
So we're effectively
building an entire, you know,
new world ourselves, right?
This, you know, this, $2 trillion industry
has bubbled up in 12 years.
Soon a majority of the
world's billionaires
will have made their
money from cryptocurrency.
I don't mean many, a majority.
This is super new.
If you think about Bitcoin
again, the most mainstream
digital asset in the
cryptocurrency universe.
That was only released in 2008,
and it really didn't come into mainstream
consciousness until 2017.
One of the best ways to view
the maturation of Bitcoin is,
if you look at mining.
This used to be something
that you could mine in your dorm room.
I know a few people who did that.
To now, you basically have
to have a very sophisticated
operation to really mine Bitcoin at scale,
to solve these increasingly
complex computer problems.
That takes a lot of electricity.
Bit Digital is a Bitcoin miner,
and we've been mining
Bitcoin in various states
like Nebraska, New York,
Georgia, and Texas and so on.
Bit Digital in particular,
looks for clean sources
of power in order to power our computers
that help solve these
mathematical problems
that produce Bitcoin.
Can't hear a damn thing in here.
Correct, it's pretty loud.
This is our warehouse
in Kearney, Nebraska.
Over here we've got a
bunch of unboxed units.
There's about 2,000 here.
And you know, frankly,
it's not great to see
them sitting here in boxes
because they could be
plugged in and making money.
What are these, M21s?
Yeah, these are all M20s.
M20s, depending on the model
and the exact moment you buy them
are gonna cost 10 to 15,000 a piece.
They're a lot heavier than they look
and you plug it in and it
starts making this commodity
we know as Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is the mother coin.
It's the first coin, it's
the first blockchain.
But I think beyond that,
Bitcoin has had a bit of
a democratizing effect.
It's created opportunities
to generate capital.
We wouldn't have had
access to that before.
You know, that was enabled by Bitcoin.
And now it's spread to a bigger ecosystem.
The basic business model of Bitcoin mining
has traditionally been to
accumulate as much Bitcoin
as possible and hold that Bitcoin
for its appreciation potential.
But there's a broader vision here.
Lending, borrowing, stock
exchanges, currency exchanges,
insurance, derivatives,
all of these now have their facsimiles
in the digital realm,
which had been created with code
rather than with brick
and mortar institutions.
And this is the landscape
that we are thinking of
when we say the word DeFi.
Trying to study and
wrap my head around DeFi
a lot more lately.
Four or five years ago, you know,
everything we were doing
was really oriented around
Bitcoin and its growing ecosystem.
Over the past few years in contrast,
everything has been oriented around DeFi.
DeFi is a collection of software projects
that run on the blockchain that enable
a host of money activities.
Things like lending and borrowing,
swapping or trading of different assets.
The creation of new
asset classes like NFTs.
You go and deposit money in
a bank and, what, you get
.75% interest at best.
Depositing in a bank,
but then they loan it out
at 10% to 20% to people.
So they're making 20 times the money
that they're giving you in return.
Whereas like DeFi can
definitely change that paradigm.
There are two promises to DeFi.
And I think they broadly fork.
So you have the idea
of financial inclusion,
where people who do not have
access to financial services
can get that access.
And then you have the idea
that for the rest of the world
that already had access
to financial services,
were now switching from
snail mail to email.
and I think it's exciting and unknown
what emergent properties
will come out of that,
when you can transact much faster
and in a much more trustless way.
I don't need five people to guarantee
that a transaction is gonna happen
if I can just automate it through a code.
Because the code is
available for anybody to see,
and that code is immutable,
you should be able to
simply look at that and say,
yes this code is doing
what that person is
saying they're gonna do,
I can verify, not trust.
The decentralized finance system is,
we believe a disruptive technology,
not unlike the early days of the internet,
that is eventually going to replace
large swaths of the
financial and monetary system
as we know it.
The potential for it to
really disrupt finance
and the banking system,
a lot of that is still very much a dream,
a vision of the crypto community,
but its potential applications
are enormous for sure.
If you think about the overall
cryptocurrency universe,
that's estimated to be $3 trillion.
Estimates for how much of that is in DeFi
is in the hundreds of
billions, 250 billion.
The speed of innovation is incredible.
There's compounding
exponential innovation.
And it's driven by the
openness of the community,
both from a software perspective,
but also a really genuine desire
to continue to add to innovations.
The blockchain is the underpinning
of all of this change.
So blockchain is the
record keeping technology.
It's this decentralized public ledger
where all of these
cryptocurrency transactions
are recorded anonymously.
So the cryptocurrency is
the medium of exchange
and the blockchain is
where that's all recorded.
Blockchain is good at three things.
It's good at storing information,
security, and allowing anyone to audit it.
That is the ultimate weapon, dare I say,
to fight back against people
who have been hiding information,
who have been threatening security,
who have been manipulating information.
It's a decentralized system,
no one owns or controls or runs it.
Meaning, if you wanted to stop this thing,
that's facilitating this
change, how do you do it?
You know, where's the leader?
Where's the CEO?
Where's the company?
There isn't one.
You can't shut down that system,
and it's the most secure
system the world has ever seen.
And so that is what
makes this all possible.
The next evolution for a lot of people
is then the Ethereum network.
Ethereum has expanded the possibilities
of what can be done with this technology.
We understood that the technology worked.
From there it was kind of
like a very quick click.
Hi, my name is Joseph Lubin.
Yeah so I was one of eight original
co-founders of Ethereum.
The Ethereum project set out to become
a new trust foundation for the planet,
to essentially effect a paradigm shift
in how the world organizes itself.
In order to be a new trust foundation,
you need to be massively
decentralized in as many dimensions
of decentralization as you can identify.
And the new trust foundation
gives us things like
digital scarcity, it gives
us trustworthy collaboration.
It enables us to transact
between people who don't know one another,
just because you can trust the programs
that are guaranteed to
execute on the blockchain.
It seemed very natural to call
this emerging decentralized
protocol, blockchain, cryptocurrency,
set of technologies, Web3.
What is Web3?
Can you explain it simply?
Let's start with Web1, how about that?
Web1, for the first time we
had access to information.
Welcome.
We had this kind
of real idealistic
notion of knowledge and
communication and information.
Goodbye.
Web2 happened, we saw a big consolidation.
You know, Facebook,
Twitter, so on and so forth.
And Web3 is really
taking the ideals of Web1
and kind of solidifying
them in a meaningful way.
Web3 is really shorthand
for a world where the users
are creating the value,
but also capturing the value.
Something that was totally lost
with the Facebooks and the Googles
and the Amazons of the world.
The people, the users are the ones
that have much more power,
that are able to create
much more value and also
are able to consequently
capture some of that value.
It's known as this amalgamation
of these different
decentralized technologies.
And this new world, essentially
that we're creating.
The first wave of the internet, right,
took multiple years.
Web2 unfolded over the course of,
you know, 10, 12 years.
And so Web3, it's just beginning.
And so that's the phase
that we're in right now.
Early on, we built smart contracts.
Probably the most interesting part
of the Ethereum network is
that it uses smart contracts.
Which are basically these
self-executing contracts
based on preset conditions.
And when those conditions take place,
there is an exchange of value
that happens automatically.
If then, this, that.
If you think about the floor
of the New York stock exchange,
or if you think about simply
buying or selling stock
in your brokerage account,
there are fees paid that are
associated with doing that.
Contrast that with clicking
a button on your computer,
without any human beings touching it,
and without any transaction fees.
That becomes much more efficient
from an economic perspective for the user.
What we've done is we've identified
certain DeFi protocols.
Then you could generate
a very good return.
It's all governed by code.
It's just software running in the cloud.
There aren't armies of human beings
working in office towers,
earning bonuses to facilitate this.
We're not participating
in DeFi at this time,
just because there's too
much regulatory uncertainty
for a public company.
So what we're doing
right now in the interim
is we're studying it.
My name is Tim Massad.
I was formerly the chairman
of the Commodity Futures
Trading Commission.
Well, the crypto sector
today is largely unregulated.
It's hard to know whether
a particular DeFi app
is going to work as promised
or whether it was created
by reputable people,
unless you've done a lot of due diligence.
How can a typical person
even begin to, say,
identify, like, what a good
project is, in this space?
I mean there's no question
that the token economy is a very volatile
asset class to be involved in.
There's tens of thousands
of cryptocurrencies
and NFTs being created every day.
And some of these things are
gonna go off a cliff to zero.
And so buyer beware.
The obvious risk is that, you know,
there is no counterparty to fall back on.
If you do lose your money
somehow, which theoretically,
you're not supposed to be
able to with a smart contract,
there's no recourse here.
You have, you don't have a
counterparty to turn back to,
that's why prime brokers exist.
That's why they calculate risk rules.
That's why exchanges
facilitate these transactions.
But by removing them, you
also remove that buffer.
Right now, if I mistype
the address in Ethereum,
that money could be gone forever, right?
And my aunt Matilda can't
lose her life savings
using Ethereum that way.
It's just not usable or
sustainable for somebody like her.
So in order to go mainstream,
you may need to invite
some centralized aspects.
Most of us can't spend hours figuring out
if a particular DeFi app is
going to work as promised
or studying the code.
So we rely on others for expertise,
for certain services, and intermediaries
often perform those functions.
The real value of a regulatory framework
is that it gives people confidence.
It gives them confidence that
whatever financial activity
they're participating in or
intermediary they're relying on
is going to do what it promised.
That they're not going to be the victim
of fraud and manipulation,
that no one's going to
abscond with their money.
This is a little bit like the
American Wild West, right?
Like there's this cutting
edge frontier out there,
freelance, stake your claim
on the potential gold rush, right?
But when you get out there, it's,
hey, there's people trying to rob you
and there's scams going on and...
Blockchain and cryptocurrencies
are a disruptive technology.
They're a young technology,
there will be exploits.
Federal investigators say
a Wild West culture has
led to a massive spike
in cryptocurrency scams.
There are a whole list
of problems with crypto.
Unreliable tech, scams.
You have like these Ponzi scheme projects
where their tokens are priced
- basically crap coins, right?
Or you have these other
projects where you deposit
your liquidity and then they do a rug pull
where they basically steal
the money out from under you.
Or basically these just
fly by night projects,
where they never really had
the intention to build it,
but they just kind of strung you along
and then they close up shop eventually.
Regulators need to step
up to address crypto's
regulatory gaps and ensure
that we're actually building
the inclusive financial
system that we need.
Essentially what DeFi is,
it's like a big casino.
It provides people with an opportunity
to make potentially huge gains
or potentially lose a ton of money.
But for the people who
end up being the house,
running the casino, it's
pretty much guaranteed gain.
The intermediate, they're the exchanges,
they're the DeFi platforms.
And beyond that, they don't
have any of the regulations
that guarantee safety,
soundness and protect customers.
It may ultimately produce some
really useful innovations.
But for the time being, it's
pretty much full service
shadow banking with nobody in charge.
Throughout the financial system
we have what are known as Know
Your Customer requirements,
which means that banks, brokers,
and other financial actors
have to verify the
identity of their customer.
And that is a means to
prevent illicit activity.
It also helps reduce fraud.
The DeFi sector will have to
figure out how to do this.
And I think really the only
way the sector can grow
and become mainstream is if
you have a regulatory framework
that sets some baseline standards.
We welcome regulation, we're eager for it
because we need clarity
and there's so much
opportunity in this space
we wanna participate in.
What I'd say is that we're hopeful
that the regulation's crafted in a way
that protects individual
investors and spurs innovation.
And doesn't just protect
the interests of incumbent
financial institutions.
So what are these guys doing?
Why are they going to these great lengths?
Are they trying to bring about,
a more stable, equitable,
inclusive kind of finance?
Or are they looking to get rich?
I would tend to believe the latter.
Miami has a very crypto friendly vibe.
And I think the industry is taking off.
It's hard to imagine what
decentralization looks like.
You come here though
and you see real people
who you've met online, or, hey,
I threw this metaverse party
and you were there and I'm
meeting you in real life.
It's all these people who
love all these esoteric pieces
of the cryptocurrency universe,
that now come together and
they can share the things
that they're passionate about.
They can share their enthusiasm,
they can share their expertise.
Their minds are open
to ideas, to dreaming,
to thinking big, to thinking differently.
As we're re-imagining money,
we're really creating
this equality future.
I think we're gonna slowly
change this disparity
between the rich and the poor.
This whole event here is
still very, very early
compared to what's gonna happen,
or what's about to happen
in crypto and NFTs.
And this space in general.
DeFi is actually in
the heart, in the skin,
everything of what we do.
It's exciting to see how many people
are getting into this space.
Art has sort of joined forces with tech.
There's enough space for everyone in here.
So we're living in the early days
of a massive paradigm shift.
We are accelerating,
into a digitized and decentralized future
where there will be a
better trust foundation.
So similar to how web technology
and internet technology
brought democracy and democratization
to access to information,
we're bringing technologists
and entrepreneurs in,
to democratize global finance.
So I actually just left my job
for 10 years at Goldman Sachs
as a VP in the risk division.
You know, covering hedge
funds and prime services.
My last day I caught a flight
to come to this convention
and really start participating
in the decentralized finance space.
As I started to realize,
I don't know, the lack
of necessity of my own
role that I was building.
My legacy helps a system
that I don't believe is
fully necessary anymore
and a system that doesn't benefit
the broad public or communities
that really need it.
It's hard to read,
but if you look at the
placard for the convention,
the Wifi password is kind of self-evident
about how a lot of these people here feel.
You know, there's an
entire financial ecosystem
that's being modeled
and created and championed
by, you know, a bunch of apes
or you know other kind of like avatars.
And that's scary to the JPMorgans
because again, they're
seeing all this growth
and they're left out.
Jamie Dimon has a very specific opinion
on cryptocurrency, he
really thinks it's a scam.
I could care less what Bitcoin trades for,
how it trades, why it
trades, who trades it,
if you're stupid enough to buy,
you'll pay the price for it one day.
But that doesn't stop JPMorgan
from having an entire department
devoted to blockchain technology.
There are so many people involved
in the traditional banking system.
I don't think the goal is to remove them,
but the question is, what is necessary?
Should we be doing things the
way we're doing them today,
simply because we've always done that?
We don't do that with telephones.
We don't do that with cars.
We don't do that with
all the other technology.
However, we are still tied to
the centralized banking system
in a way that is unnecessary.
So major financial institutions
are for the large part
aware of the technology.
Many of them have strict regulation,
that they have to pay attention
to and are constrained by.
Maybe some of them will
put their head in the sand
and think all of this will go away.
They won't last very long, I assume.
It's either, you know,
come in and participate
or basically die, right?
Or get displaced in some form or fashion.
So I know that banks are working
on their own blockchain solutions.
They're keeping up with
everything that's going on.
And it's the same with the governments.
They're not really
talking about this stuff,
but they're there,
they're listening and they're learning
because they know that this is the future.
As you think about, you know,
the billions of people that
are coming onto the internet
first time, having an internet
native financial infrastructure
is gonna allow all of these people
that are normally
unbanked to become banked.
And it's definitely gonna be very big
for financial inclusivity
across the entire world.
We're not waiting for the
big banks to open the door,
we're not waiting for the federal reserve
to give a thumbs up.
People are able to create and cultivate
their own communities, their
own ideas, their own products,
and capture more of that value directly
with fewer middlemen.
That's really the promise of blockchain.
And so we're at that stage of
this industry's development
where everybody's starting to get it.
You know, consensus just being reached
amongst all the industries
that this is real
and it ain't going anywhere.